العوده الى عصر ما قبل الانترنت امنيه لدى
كثيرين هذه الايام لكنها بالطبع ليست من
الصميم القلب كما يعتقد كثيره مجموعه من
سكان الاصليين في اندونيسيا انتقلت من حيز
الاماني الى التنفيذ حيث طلبت مجموعه بدو
للسكان الاصليين والمكونه من 26 الف نسمه
في مقاطعه بانتين بجزيره جاوا طلبت من
السلطات قطع الاتصال بشبكه الانترنت عن
منطقتها السبب في رايهم هو تقليل التاثير
السلبي للهواتف الذكيه والعالم الافتراضي
على افرادها كما انهم يرون في الانترنت
تهديدا لاسلوب حياه السكان والصحه العقليه
للشباب السلطات الاندونيسيه ردت على
مطالبهم بالقول اذ قال مسورون انهم يريدون
التكيف مع ما يريده افراد مجتمع بادوي
وعلينا ان نحافظ على تقاليدهم ومعارف هم
المحليه وافقت تعبير مسؤول حكومي
اندونيسيا بختار المجتمع المنعزل العيشه
في الغابه ورفض التكنولوجيا وخدمات المال
وتعليم التقليديه ويقيم افراد هذا المجتمع
في ثلاث قرى في تمتد على مساحه 4000 هكتار
على بعد ساعات بالسياره من العاصمه جاكرتا
الدكتور الحاج ولد ابراهيم الاستاذ
الجامعي يعني ربما تكون هذه اول مره نقرا
فيها خبرا عن مجموعه من البشر لا تريد
الانترنت
برايك هل هذا نموذج قابل للتكرار
لا اعتقد مساء الخير صباح الخير شكرا
جزيلا على الاستضافه لا اعتقد ان النموذج
مجتمع في جزيره جاوا قابل للتعميم هذه
المجموعه مجموعه هذا المجتمع ينتمي
لمجتمعات سكان الاصليه
بناء حتى معتقداته الدينيه مبنيه على على
على
ما يسمى العزله الطوعيه
فقداتهم الاصليه هي مبنيه على التصالح مع
الطبيعه
كل كل المعطيات الجديده الحديثه سواء كان
حتى التعليم بانه هذه مجتمع البادوي ايضا
يربط حتى التعليم وانظمه الجبايه وانظمه
الطرق والعربات والسيارات وهذه كلها
مربوطه في اعتقادات لانها تضر الطبيعه
ومعتقداتهم الدينيه مؤسسه على التصالح مع
الطبيعه
لذلك هذا النموذج سيبقى معزول ولا اعتقد
انه قابل للتعمير مع الاسف سيكون بعض بعض
لا مشكله في ذلك ربما نتحدث اكثر عن
خصوصيه هذا المجتمع
المعزول كيف لمثل هذه الاثنيه مثلا هذه
هذا المجتمع ان يرفض كل ما وصل اليه البشر
من ادوات التطوير يعني حتى التعليم حتى
الغذاء حتى العادات والتقاليد قبل الوصول
للانترنت
بالنسبه هذه المجموعه مجموعه عندها معتقد
يسمى الكوكو ويمكن ترجمته بالانتماء
الانتماء
مبدا عقيده الانتماء هذه عندها مبدئيا
مبدا
التغيير الكلي رفض التغيير الكلي او تقيير
الحد الادنى يعني هم في النهايه
يدركون انهم يعيشون في دوله وهم هم
بالنهايه مثلا يعيشون في دوله اندونيسيا
عندها قوانين ولكن هو نوع من المقاومه
الثقه بهم في النهايه مجبر على لان
المجموعه مثلا حسب الارقام التي
تحدث عنها 26 الف
في مجموعه مثلا خارجه عن الطور هي تقبل
بالتعليم التعليم الحديث
الدراجات الناريه كلها ولكن في النهايه
هذه مجموعه منعزله داخل هذه 26 الف هم مع
تقداتهم وطبعا هم معزولين هي تقريبا حسب
تقديرات الامم المتحده توجد مئه مئه
مجموعه في مجموعه مثلا متفرقه 50% منها
توجد في جزيره في منطقه الامازون طبعا
مجموعه قليله موجوده في افريقيا
لانه المجموعات المعزوله في العالم كثيره
لسيمه في حوض الامازون وهنالك مجموعات
يعني لم لم تختلط اصلا بالبشر الاخرين ولم
تختلط باي مات احدهم مات اخرهم ضمن
المجموعات كان بقي فيها فرد واحد ومات لكن
هذه المجموعه ليست كذلك هي تعرف ماذا لدى
البشر ماذا لدى بقيه البشر مباشره ايضا
تعرف ماذا لديهم من تكنولوجيا بتعرف ماذا
لديهم من تقدم لكنها تقرر ان تظل معزوله
هل هنالك نموذج اخر يشبه ذلك
طبعا طبعا
في النهايه خصوصيه هذه المجموعه ان هذه
الطريق من المعتقدات اصيله عند هذه عند
هذه المجموعه ولكن طبعا هي توجد حتى في
المجتمعات الغربيه مثلا المجتمعات الغربيه
فيها مجموعات مثلا تسمى
الموجوده في المانيا موجوده في اوروبا
الغربيه
مثلا
هي مجتمعات حديده تستخدم الهواتف ولكنها
تقريبا انتقائيه باستخداماتها لمعطيات
الحديثه مثلا هي تعيش في الكهوف وتعيش بعض
الاحيان عاريه عندها شواطئ خاصه وعندها
فلسفه تقريبا مرتبطه ايضا بالمعتقدات
الهندوسيه وموجوده في قعر اوروبا هذه ليست
مجتمعات في الامازون موجوده مثلا بقاع
اوروبا الغربيه في المانيا مثلا
حسب قلايه على نموذج مجموعه في في ولكن
للنهايه فكره الانعزال مثلا تجتاح لجميع
مثلا فكره
الانترنت
الاجهزه الذكيه والادمان والافراط افراط
استخدام الاجهزه الذكيه يدفع الكثيرين في
اتباع هذا النموذج ولو انهم معتقدات
مختلفه
القطع مثلا الى الكهوف لمده من الزمن حتى
ويبتعد عن الحياه الحديثه لكن نشكرك شكرا
جزيلا من باريس الدكتور الحاج ولد ابراهيم
استاذ الجامع المختص في الانثروبولوجيا
الثقافيه